[Música]
y hoy en directo
vamos a washington el senado hundió el
proyecto con el que se buscaba proteger
el derecho al aborto convirtiéndolo en
una norma federal la llamada ley de
protección de la salud de la mujer sólo
contó con 49 de los 60 votos que
necesitaba para su aprobación y es que
todos los 50 republicanos se opusieron y
a ellos se unió el demócrata joe manchin
esta votación apresurada impulsada por
el partido demócrata sea el medio de los
temores de que la corte suprema- pueda
revocar la sentencia del roe versus wade
que garantiza la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo desde 1973 en todo el país
vamos entonces a la capital
estadounidense con nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez hola cristóbal un
placer saludarlo y cuéntenos porque los
demócratas siguieron adelante con este
proyecto aún sabiendo que no contaban
con los votos necesarios tienen alguna
motivación política
si varios demócratas
afirmaron que aunque sabían que este
resultado iba a ser negativo avanzaron
con esta votación para hacer un llamado
a la acción un llamado a la acción a sus
votantes para
para que en noviembre en las elecciones
legislativas salgan a votar por los
candidatos que pues se sumaron a esta
iniciativa de proteger el aborto se
sabía ya que eran 53 demócratas y 50
republicanos dividido el senado así va a
ser muy difícil lograr estos 60 votos
sin embargo los demócratas insistieron
en que querían hacer ver a los
republicanos como extremistas y no y que
no les preocupaba el tema de la
protección a la salud de las mujeres sin
embargo pues muchos analistas acá en
eeuu dicen que los demócratas han tenido
ya varias oportunidades en el pasado
para avanzar este tipo de legislaciones
que protejan el aborto y protejan a la
mujer pero hasta ahora después de esta
información que se filtró de la corte
suprema de justicia que en eeuu hacen
algo dicen que él ya es demasiado tarde
para que los demócratas puedan lograr
algo frente al aborto después de todo el
trabajo que vienen haciendo los
republicanos bueno y si ya es muy tarde
también sigamos hablando del tema
político porque recientes encuestas
muestran que el derecho al aborto es
apoyado por al menos un 60 por ciento
los estadounidenses cuéntenos cómo
influye este tema en las elecciones de
medio término
si esta es una encuesta que saca el
centro de investigación pero en esta
encuesta también se revela que el 37% de
los estadounidenses dicen que apoyan
medidas en contra del aborto y lo que
varios centros de pensamiento acá en
washington resaltan es que el tema del
aborto es mucho más sensible para los
votantes conservadores para los votantes
republicanos es decir este tema impulsa
mucho más a los votantes republicanos a
salir a votar el día de las elecciones
más de lo que le genera a los demócratas
dicen ciertos analistas además hay que
resaltar también que pues los
republicanos vienen durante muchos años
haciendo un trabajo local estatal
eligiendo gobernadores eligiendo jueces
estatales para precisamente tumbar y
restringir el aborto en todo el país se
calcula además que de aprobarse estas
medidas en contra del aborto en la corte
suprema- serían 26 estados los que
empezarían a poner medidas que
restrinjan el aborto en todo el país al
respecto
joe biden emitió un comunicado diciendo
que precisamente basado en esta encuesta
la mayoría de los estadounidenses no se
sienten representados por la decisión
que hoy toma el senado y que
eventualmente tomaría la corte suprema
de justicia
gracias cristóbal por este reporte y
nosotros seguimos con más en directo
américa